carmencore they are quite possibly the
most confusing team in the history of
competitive valorant despite having a
franchise spot and top tier Talent like
the likes of scream it sometimes looks
like they've never touched the game
before XMS just walk backwards and pick
up the rifle scream cart by just walk
backwards and pick up the rifle he's
gonna survive instead of going and
picking up the rifle the scream needs in
the next I cannot believe it they've
become the car accident that you can't
look away from and Incredibly it's
gotten them some Die Hard fans
[Music]
all right when you think of a tier one
franchise valoran team you probably
think of some of the best players in the
world right when you think of a
mechanically blessed veteran igl you
probably think of a roster that has Rock
Solid fundamentals and a Killer Instinct
on paper that's carmencore but if you've
seen just a few rounds of these boys
play you'd know that they aren't the
well-oiled machine that they should be
I'm literally watching the pair of books
what is going on he's in spawn he didn't
buy he forgot to buy with 3 500 credits
because he took his headphones off
but before we get into this absolute
clown Fiesta we need to talk about how
we actually got here carmencore is a
pretty legendary French orc with plenty
of success and other titles such as
League of Legends and Rocket league and
in 2022 kcor decided to dip their toes
into valorin signing a team of mostly
unknown French players but when valran
announced the franchise teams for the
2023 VCT carmencore was one of them and
just a couple of months later the org
would sign scream his brother navera and
former French CS journeyman XMS and
let's just say there was a lot of hype
[Music]
prior to joining K course scream and
Navarro were on Team Liquid but after a
very lackluster 2022 the boys needed a
fresh start and with screams storied CS
go history and presence as a content
creator he brought a ton of fans with
him so everyone was eager to see what
these guys could do and after a pretty
solid showing at the VCT lock-in k core
would start off hot going 2-0 in the
first regular season matchup however
that would Mark the end of the good
times for kcor because over the course
of the next month or so they would fail
to win a single map against another team
now I know you might be thinking who
cares there's always going to be bad
teams in a league that struggle to win
it's the way these things work but
here's the thing kcor wasn't just
getting beat by more skilled teams they
were losing rounds in spectacular
fashion Casey back in the fight and Cena
has an operator on the retake good Kill
from zip hand and a second from CNET 2v2
four seconds
please plant the spike you have to for
money please I don't care about saving
try to plant the spike or you are
Captain a thousand credits
and that they take the choice of saving
the guns don't go for the spike plant
could have been punished learning moment
learning moment though because I've seen
Casey do this before misplaced utility
seemingly zero mid-round calling
absolutely no comprehension of the
game's economy you name it k core was
up almost every aspect of the
game it got to the point that K core's
fan base turned into an even bigger cult
following people became obsessed with
watching them play because it was just
so goddamn chaotic eventually popular
caster and analyst Sideshow would start
hosting watch parties dedicated to k
core and each week thousands of people
would tune in to experience the madness
together time
you
melons but why why was k core making
these fundamental mistakes that were
costing them games it was almost Beyond
explanation favorite on Ascent was round
17 where XMS has an OP they don't even
have enough there are often they have
XMS often and he smokes himself off he
uses both smokes at the beginning of
these rounds every time so he doesn't
have them for the mid-rounding he smokes
himself even though he's public
gets distracted
and if you thought it couldn't get any
worse you'd be sadly mistaken because
just last week one of their players knew
Zera just straight up left the team and
since the rosters are locked in for the
season they can't replace him so they're
stuck playing with their assistant coach
as a substitute so the team is obviously
cursed by some unknown Eldritch horn but
the same time someone needs to be at
fault right sure you can call scream and
XMS washed all you want but at the very
least they are still mechanically
skilled players scream is the one tap
machine who to this day still has the
highest headshot percentage in CS go you
don't just lose that overnight well
since the team was making these
fundamental errors most obvious thing
people could point to was screams igling
as good of a player as he is Scream was
never really known for his ability to
lead a team and many were wondering if
the team would be better off with
someone else at the helm that way scream
and his brother could just go kill well
it turns out that news era leaving might
have been a blessing in disguise over
the last week k-core decided to give the
igl role to the assistant coach turned
player and everything would come down to
the match yesterday against Koi Koi was
a team with a similar history to kcor
they won their first match but ever
since then it's been all zeros however
koi is not known for their inability to
play the game properly they just lose so
this matchup could have very well been
the nail in the coffin for cake core and
despite winning the first map K Corps
started to fall into some familiar
patterns so Nevada should be breaking
this now to distract and instead he's
going on the massive wrap around to CT
call dementia oh my God no bro no no no
no way
[Applause]
[Music]
but by the grace of God K Corps managed
to come together and squeak out a win
and let me just say it was high
so he's repositioning that's fine that's
good
really good paranoid them down nice
[Applause]
oh yeah
and looking back at the stats of the
game who is at the top of the
leaderboards scream and Navarro so maybe
maybe that was the problem the entire
time and to be fair to scream it's not a
really unique one eye gelling is the
hardest role in plenty of games and over
the years we've seen a lot of teams
struggle in that department especially
in CS go zaiwu Nico Stewie all these
players were held back at some point
because they were busy trying to lead
the team while also being the star
player and I think that's sort of what
was going on with k core the question is
will their success continue and if they
only manage to improve ever so slightly
will they still get all of this
attention their new fandom was built
upon them being an absolutely chaotic
dumpster fire so what happens if they
stop being that but part of me feels
like it almost doesn't matter anymore
kakor have become the ultimate Underdog
at this point and as long as they keep
that energy things will always be
entertaining and at the end of the day
having fun is what the this is all about
why you beat me bro
bald Sideshow with the Muzzy Elite combo
I remember him from uh the OverWatch
days and he was still just as funny but
then I kind of didn't see him for a
while and yeah the Chrome is domus with
the the porn star stash it's it's a
great look nothing but respect